[Musique]
josée legault michel c'est au jai alai
castonguay bonsoir
alors voilà ça pas pris de temps le coût
de la vie c'est une évidence je le dire
tout début d'émission un sujet qui
préoccupe beaucoup de gens puis de
l'incertitude économique alors et la cac
et les libéraux aujourd'hui ils sont
allés de promesses de baisses d'impôts
monsieur legault quand même rare est
revenu une deuxième fois qu'une autre
annonce dit ce n'est pas terminé je vais
vous envoyer des chèques comme l'autre
fois également 400 et 600 de là on les
écoute les deux ponts revient de suite
évidemment l'on prend pas pour acquis
qu'on va être le présent mais on pense
important d'en discuter en société puis
qu'on se donne tous comme objectif d'ici
dix ans de réduire et où toutes les
échelles d'impôt de deux points et demi
je pense que
ça va aider les québécois
avoir plus d'argent dans leur
portefeuille
pendant que les coffres du gouvernement
legault se remplissent les poches des
québécois se vide notre plan
portefeuille quand l'un qu'on lance
aujourd'hui c'est de remettre en moyenne
5000 $ par année dans les poches de
chaque famille québécoise
bon général nous à démêler tout ça un
peu tout à l'heure 5000 $ et madame
anglade additionne le gel des tarifs du
drot l'absence de tvq sur certains
produits les baisses d'impôts qui arrive
plus tôt que c'est de la cac alors là on
lira des précisions mais avec vous je
veux surtout parler de la motivation
politique p de ce sujet-là josé il est
incontournable et c'est écrit dans le
ciel ça leur arrivait à les chiffres
allaient arriver vite
oui mais ça avait été annoncé je pense
pas par presque tous les partis là au
déclenchement de dimanche et ce qui est
un peu celle à comprendre dans le cas de
la cac c'est que d'habitude des baisses
d'impôts surtout en situation ou au
québec on a encore des services publics
qui craque de partout particulièrement
en santé et en éducation
c'est une mesure habituellement assez
électoralistes la caq a pas vraiment
besoin de ça
sur l'inflation il doit par contre
intervenir parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
québécois qui n'arrivent tout simplement
plus mais la question c'est est-ce qu'il
intervient au bon endroit et avec les
bonbons tard si on regarde une baisse
d'impôts par exemple de paulilles pour
les gens qui gagnent 80 dollars est
moins la première année ces 630 $ sur
une année ça c'est 12 $ par semaine
je suis pas sur la coque on paye un gros
loyer une grosse hypothèque ou une
grosse épicerie avec ça donc c'est ça
moi que j'ai de la difficulté à
m'expliquer deux parties que le parti
libéral sont là dedans
de peu par paraître électoralisme parce
qu'il est vraiment vraiment dans le
trouble ça s'explique un peu mieux sur
le côté beauty look avec son besoin et
c'est clairement d'aller aussi mais je
pense pas mais ça fait quand même partie
de son adn il le rappeler aujourd'hui le
portefeuille mécha sur oger comment
j'avais vu les annonces aujourd'hui
cette compétition fiscale on peut dire
oui c'est ça qui est dommage parce qu'à
un moment donné on voyait une surenchère
qui parraine ce projet j'ai tendance à
peluches croire les chiffres de gérald
fillion que chef du parti libéral et de
ceux de la caq aussi quand il dit ça va
coûter 11 milliards touche que la cac
pour cause c'est beaucoup de sous en
plus de ça on va aller chercher ça en
différents des paiements au fonds des
générations
là il faut qu'on se pose des questions
seront encore besoin de fonds des
générations sont d'accord que ça serve
pour ça sa mission originale où c'est
devenu une espèce de petite caisse pour
les gouvernements pendant les élections
parce que ce n'était pas chose et être
cette affaire le fonds des générations
il ya beaucoup de groupes de jeunes des
gens qui réagissent aujourd'hui et cela
peut se poser cette affaire non alors
mais 11 milliards c'est beaucoup de chou
quand on sait que lille va y avoir
probablement une récession au début de
l'année prochaine et puis et la session
mais on sait quand ça commence quand ces
roms a commencé film ok alec
commencer cette compétition aujourd'hui
fiscale
pas très surpris beaucoup d'argent dans
les coffres du gouvernement écoute on
est déjà de retour de budgétaire malgré
que la part du ministre ne soit pas
terminé et si on enlevait les versements
très généreux au fonds des générations
aux frères surplus déjà moi je trouve ça
sain qu'on se pose des questions pour le
fonds des générations qui ne devrait pas
être un dogme et de l'outil qui a été
utile qui me semble être beaucoup moins
utile maintenant écouter on va verser
3.5 milliards de dollars cette année
dans le fonds des générations dans trois
ans on est rendu à ce point 1 milliard
par année pour un québec où on est déjà
à l'équilibré budgétaire et dont le
poids de la dette par rapport au pib
d'indécent tout seul parce que
l'économie croît et en italie qui libre
on est déjà en train en contrôle de la
dette sont pas toujours été le cas je
pense que le fonds des générations eu
son utilité je pense que c'est ça on
dira ce qu'on le donne en baisse
d'impôts est ce qu'on le donne dans un
plan climat attendez vous souhaitez bec
solidaire pige peut-être dans le fonds
des générations pour son lent sur les
changements climatiques dimanche
peut-être que d'autres parties vont
avoir d'autres idées ça je trouve ça
quand même intéressant parce que
je ne pense pas que ce soit une vache
sacrée - samedi je ne pense pas que ça
de l2 clé dans l'estuaire
j'aimais pas supposé servir de la petite
caisse par des
rachats
josé non peut-être pas monsieur chasse
est d'accord avec alec d'ailleurs il
faut se souvenir que le fonds des
générations avait été écrit sous jean
charest en réaction au manifeste des
lucides
manifeste le néo libérale de droite le
qui l'aurait nouveaux édifices est elle
adaptée tout l'équité
intergénérationnelle mais la vraie
équité intergénérationnelle
c'est de léguer des services publics de
qualité
là on a presque 20 milliards en ce
moment dans le fonds des générations
on va atteindre 37 milliards d'ici 2027
la question n'est pas si on doit toucher
au fonds des générations moi aussi je
pense que oui mais ce qu'on doit toucher
pour des baisses d'impôts ou pour
bonifier les services mais voilà voilà
le débat qui va s'engager c'est ça qui
est intéressant vous avez dit josé il
n'y avait pas besoin de ça monsieur
legault tellement que ça va bien que je
fais écouter c'est très court il était à
rivière du loup mais rencontraient des
candidats de la région de l'est du
québec dont le candidat qui va être
content pascal bérubé de matane alors on
écoute monsieur legault qui parle à son
candidat comme pascal
[Musique]
on va donner une bonne règle notre ami
pascal dont monsieur legault pascal
bérubé se connaissent très bien monsieur
berry but à travailler pour monsieur
legault requin taupe et cuts et déjà on
disait même à ce qu'il veut pas se
joindre à la caq mais plus maintenant
alors michel si je commence avec vous je
mens je vous ai fait écouter ça pour
illustrer que monsieur legault il voit
graal il va pas il veut aller pour le
grand jeu là
il veut aller pour le grain jeu il veut
s'avère 50 essais capable de ça vibre
pas là mais je persiste mais amène des
objectifs partisans qui ne sait aussi de
remplacer le pq et on le voit dans tout
bon donner une ride à pascal se sait
c'est de bonne guerre pendant quand on
raconte le candidat mais quand on a vu
ce qu'il a fait par exemple aux îles de
la madeleine où il est allé chercher le
maire actuel pour ce
qui est de la lah cpq à la fin je pense
que monsieur legault ne veut pas boire
plus que deux ou trois pistes serait
bien qu a eue
québec avec soin mais pas plus que ça
quand on reviendra au parlement ok là tu
rapidement josé
sociétaires c'est l'objectif de laquelle
depuis sa création c'est c'était de
déloger le parti québécois c'est la
mission est accomplie moi dans cette
petite saynète lorsque j'ai vu surtout
c'est un chef qui essaie d'encourager un
plus aux codes du doigt parce que tu es
frh ma pascal bérubé c'est justement ces
dix ans c'est possible c'est très beaux
lots inverse de son côté
cécile peut provoquer alec un petit
moulin bas la politique n'est pas un
sport pour les coeurs tendres alors
françois legault ça c'est celui d'un
taux de liquidation il
y compris matane matapédia même si je
suis d'accord avec josé mettons que
celle là est un peu plus difficile très
bien québec solidaire
santé aujourd'hui
on a fait un lancement hier qui s a été
souligné que non le soumis hier dans
l'émission avec beaucoup de gens
sherbrooke à saint françois de
sherbrooke temps compté de
saint-françois prêt du côté de
sherbrooke où il y aura une lutte
intéressante
la santé incontournable également on va
écouter le chef de québec solidaire
tifo c'est revenir à une approche où il
ya une première ligne très facilement
accessible et pour nous ça passe par
cette revalorisation là cette refonte du
8 heures pour que ça devienne une porte
d'entrée simple et universel pour les
systèmes de santé
si on peut écouter tout de suite je vais
faire deux pour un la la langue paul st
pierre plamondon peut s'intéresser à
quand je dis allons faire on touche à
douai à peu près tous les sujets
importants la première journée on va
coûter pas le st pierre plamondon qui
promet lui une nouvelle loi sur
ce matin je vous annonce donc que dans
les 100 premiers jours d'un gouvernement
du parti québécois il y aura une
nouvelle loi 100 qui sera à la hauteur
du défi linguistique devant nous
concrètement ce que ça signifie
l'application de la loi 101 au cégep une
immigration économique 100% francophone
des mesures fortes en culture qui est
notre point de rassemblement
alors je veux c'est que je vais
présenter les deux par expert je sois y
élève de commenter le début de campagne
et de q s et du parti québécois josé
le parti québécois c'est clair que c'est
c'est la stratégie pour la campagne
c'est à dire on le parti québécois vise
pour essayer de survivre sa clientèle
qu'il a perdu en majeure partie qui est
allé à la cac c'est à dire sa cliente
est souverainiste mais déçu du pq est
aussi qui pourraient potentiellement
être issu de la loi 96 qu'est ce que ça
va fonctionner si on verra mais c'est
clair que c'est ça et l'indépendance
bien entendu donc revenir à sa raison
d'être les yeux puis il ya vraiment plus
rien à perdre sur sur l' annonce
l'engagement je devrais dire de québec
solidaire sur la santé coûte et
chacune de mes rides et demie ridules
dans mon visage sont pour à chaque fois
que j'ai entendu un chef de parti s'ils
promettent une meilleure première ligne
au québec depuis au dessus de 20 ans il
comptait les loups commencent en avoir
pas mal donc et je le dis pas pour
ridiculiser je pense que tout le monde
essaie de chercher quelque chose mais il
reste le fond de la question la première
ligne ça reste un ou deux médecins de
famille et ça malheureusement on a
baissé les bras grosso modo et tout le
reste ça saucissonne des patients entre
être envoyés à tel petit service service
et l on voit aussi les problèmes avec le
guichet d'accès à la première ligne du
ministre dubé
je sais pas moi c'est moi
personnellement ça j'ai ensuite assez
découragés je pense que québécois c'est
ce que j'allais dire vous n'êtes pas la
seule à décourager beaucoup de québécois
la première ligne est laissée geste est
à l'origine ça pour ça l'émission pour
voulu rester là travailler leurs
salariés bon un michel ces commentaires
je vous laisse libre l'anglo santé
d'abord en santé on essaie de leur faire
un peu la réforme que le sud du br fait
pour pour la première ding et c'est vrai
que même si on est médecin de famille si
la petite fait une autre cité mardi soir
peut-être comme il nous aidera pas eu un
trou c'est vrai la question c'est est ce
que la ligue
c'est ça un bon fond qui a eu des bons
fonctionné c'est pour sûr ça non plus ça
barde une infrastructure assez lourdes
mercy lors il est capable par le
téléphone a qu'une infirmière qui vole
qui va faire le triage de vous envoyer à
la bonne place tout de suite pour avoir
ces points sur le diabète un détail dans
sa ferme
quand tu es la nouvelle doit s'arrêter
ça fait partie de ce qu'il reste de ce
traité jour pq c'est à dire provenant
dépendance tout de suite entre même de
van der sar tout de suite on veut
ramener des gens qui se disaient
dépendance et qui disent qu'ils vont
voter ailleurs est-ce que ça va marcher
je pas sûr mais quand on est la
situation du parti québécois c'est
peut-être la chose essayez quoi d'autre
pourrait-il faire en fait ben voilà alec
rapidement sur la santé c'est un sujet
important incontournable un amendement
ne voyez va y aller avec ses proposons
aussi c'est déjà commencé là mais
effectivement est ce que josé souligner
c'est comment on peut croire à sa c6 ils
ont un déficit de crédibilité
tous les policiers ont un déficit de
crédibilité et c'est peut-être ce qui
est d'un peu christian dubé parce qu'il
est très bien respectée les gens
apprécient christian dubé donc dans le
difficile totale de crédibilité c'est
peut-être celui qui en a le moins s'il
ya être de françois legault bon ramener
les clc à l'avant plan la réalité c'est
que depuis quinze ans les groupes de
médecine familiale ont entrepris le ciel
s'est alors si on veut revaloriser les
clsc ou déshabiller les groupes de
médecine familiale qui est vécu et ce
beau dire c'est pas une question de
structure c'est un peu quand même une
question de structure aussi facile à
mettre en place ce que ce qu'on voudrait
puis éliminé le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire des infirmières tous les
partis le promettent depuis des années
la caq y compris on n'est pas capable
d'y arriver parce qu'on manque de
personnel et que j'attends on peut le
promettre mais c'est loin d'être certain
que ça va merci christian offrir un
d'intimider en alberta grande prairie
vendredi on écoute
langues
alors le ministre fédéral jean chinois
dit aujourd'hui on n'exclut pas de
revoir la sécurité est ce que ça ne
devrait pas être une évidence on en a
déjà parlé à ce panel que les ministres
fédéraux soient mieux encadrés mieux
protégés comme c'est le cas au québec
je crains c'est que vous allez
comme c'est le cas dans tous les pays du
g7 et du g20 cette espèce de naïveté
candeur canadienne où on y montre comme
ça ici on n'est pas comme aux etats-unis
c'est n'importe quoi il ya eu une
fusillade à l'assemblée nationale le
tirage est entrée à la chambre des
communes il ya des gens qui de plus en
plus excités par les réseaux sociaux
vont s'en prendre physiquement aux élus
y étant de renforcer leur sécurité ça
m'apparaît une urgence qu'on y
réfléchisse encore est une aberration je
ne comprends pas pourquoi on n'est pas
rendus des gens une étape supplémentaire
c'est la base un chauffeur qui soit
aussi gardes du corps comme au québec ça
devrait être ça au canada depuis des
années michel
je suis totalement d'accord exclu il
veut dire écoutez je m'excuse mais une
ministre et ministre déléguée au sport
amateur au québec en plus de sécurité
qu'il avait
quelque chose qui marche pas et en été
mais il fera pas ça qu on n'avait pas
besoin de ça là certains de revoir ça
n'a pas été menacé physiquement mais
carmen ces genres de
jeu joseph
bah oui c'est sûr que je n'en reviens
pas que toi toujours pas fait écouter on
est dans une ère de plus en plus
dangereuse est ce qu'on a vu avec la
ministre il n y avait pas de violence
physique mais il y avait une violence
verbale
exacerbée extrêmement menaçante et s'il
y avait eu des gardes de sécurité
ce gars là il y aura pas de finir sa
première phrase donc ça c'est
inacceptable il faut protéger les
ministres et les femmes sont des cibles
particulières en ce moment aux tâches et
les politiciennes que chez nous les
journalistes mais la ccta que tous les
ministres soient bien protégés tous les
chefs de partis aussi les chefs
d'opposition tout le monde au fédéral
écouter
on a changé d'ère comme dirait l'autre
partie c'est une heure plus violentes et
c'est une ère plus menaçante en grande
partie à cause de l'affluence du trump
esmel convoi des libertés tous angles
alors il faut faire quelque chose c'est
sûr c'est ce faux pas tendre qui arrive
quelques j'ai raison de souligner cette
espèce de naïveté un peu agaçante là un
peu exaspérant dedans nous c'est pas
comme ça très bien merci beaucoup à vous
droit ces partis cette campagne merci à
très bientôt au revoir